major announcement here at answer the
Internet the reason we've been on hiatus
for a little while it's because we're
busy putting out answer the Internet the
card game we've had people in the
comments basically not stop asking and
it asked some fair questions when
where's the game how can we get this as
a place to have a giant list yes there
is here it is now you can buy it from
the link in the description or you can
get it at barstool sports Walmart Amazon
and Spencer Gifts also breaking news
season two is back on Tuesday featuring
the one and only Bill burr so make sure
you watch like subscribe and comment who
you want to see for the rest of season
two all right
hey what's up guys I'm here with my boy
Cody Oh would you rather [ __ ] yourself
every time you have an orgasm what I get
these [ __ ] ones would rather straight
yourself every time you have an orgasm
or get a random boner every time you
talk a random boner every time you talk
to a dude you want to [ __ ] yourself I'd
get a boner all day he'll have to deal
with it he can hang his hat on it would
you rather suck one here but the classic
the classic snail question would you
rather suck one dick for 50k or get five
K for every dick you suck damn
what would oh yeah cuz I'm thinking I
could do like you think you do 10 dix
[ __ ] dicks think about ten dicks
know think about 10 dicks you know who's
the dude of the neighborhood some people
think about 10 days okay alright who's
the dude is the [ __ ] uh like the
[ __ ] professional hot dog guy yeah
yeah he could probably make a shitload
of money doing this right here man yeah
yeah singular
yeah singular did you rather know when
you're gonna die or how you're going to
die dude I'm a hypochondriac how I'm
gonna die
I don't care what just tell me what it
is so I can smoke cigarettes and get
back to it
[ __ ] I miss smoking so bad that's how
good tobacco is still like you want to
know when you're like I don't care if I
smoke
can't smoke right now cuz I seriously do
the opposite way I would say if when I'm
gonna die until I get a diet 80 I'll
[ __ ] smoke and then I don't care
going fast in a car no car crash I'm
going 90 everywhere I'm [ __ ] laying
on the gas you got to look at it you
gotta you gotta you gotta jump the route
on this he's gotta be like oh [ __ ] I
didn't die smoking butts next question
do you think there's more porn stars or
murders in the world someone that like
does porn yeah no I don't know I don't
know I don't know I think everyone can
be a porn set that's a great thing like
make like yeah she's a porn sorry she's
she's [ __ ] in the top 20 of pornhub
like you're a [ __ ] porn sorry like
you can be other things too like I'm a
porn sir but I model too like but you're
still points are like don't forget what
got you there sweetie so yeah I think
there's more porn stars in the world
than murderers I mean over all of the
time then I guess murders but like
currently [ __ ] I don't know this was
really her question I really don't know
how many murders there's probably more
there's a lot of like amateur porn stars
like yeah there's more important sires
we just you know that makes me happy
murderers aren't cool would you rather
have a dog's personality in a cat body
or a cat's personality in a dog body I'm
not sure exactly but I don't want to be
a cat at all so whatever one of these is
not being a cat you know see that's the
thing you would have the dog body but
the brain of a cat
kind of or a cat but then the other way
you'd have the body of a cat everyone
would think you're a cat so would you
rather know you're a cat or have other
people think you're a catch
I'd rather probably do euthanasia you
know yeah no offense to catch anything
but also [ __ ] cats so basic appeases of
loneliness that are in your apartment
would you rather every time you laugh a
dog dies every time you fall in love
there's a genocide what a [ __ ] question
oh no no I know the answer I hear here's
the deal this so bad look I love my dog
lifes and I love laughing so I don't
think I could kill a dog every time I
laughed but it and I fall in love a few
times dude like so probably the genocide
as bad as it's like no wait stop but
everyone stop
please no I sound like that I mean just
I'm like I don't fall in love often if
ever like you're safe some country or
large group of people is safe would you
rather give up sex or porn for one year
I could I would rather give up I'd say
porn for it I'd rather give up porn for
you I wanna I mean I want to well is
this raw dog sex or condom sex that's a
big road easy sex nah you can't give up
Road easy sex condom sex is a different
thing it's just you know you're just
jerking off you know you're just yeah
it's you're having sex with a condom not
the woman or a guy whatever your
preference is I don't [ __ ] care
transgender animals whatever they'll be
happy right whoo Beyonce I guess I'd
rather I'd rather give up I'd rather
give a point everybody to a point I
wanna have sex yeah where are these
because Chrissie chlamydia in the house
would you rather have a dick as your
nose or a nose as your dick
you'd like me to answer this I'm sure
and I I guess if I had to choose i'ma go
with a dick nose dick I'm gonna go blow
the nose dick just you know so I could
have a normal life somewhat oh yeah but
you don't walk it around that yeah well
don't you pants I got a cold how much
money would it take for you to not know
how to read 100 million I mean I would
just be like hey you read this right I
have a hundred million dollars here's a
thousand dollars read this [ __ ] to me
right hey you know how I pay you start
writing [ __ ] isn't that the answer more
than a hundred million I'll put you on
[ __ ] salary Jesus Christ don't don't
you have interns here hey Denny you guys
want to be my reader but you can come
with me cool places get the [ __ ] out of
this building and then just reach it and
I'll be like hey thanks for reading that
here's a sandwich